the opening scene portrays a bleak image
of Earth where the volume of garbage has
exceeded that of wild species adversely
impacting the human living environment
to address this pressing issue of Victor
Choi the founder of PDR technology has
developed a novel solution through
biological genetic engineering which
involves creating a new type of
cockroach named Capri Victor claims that
these cockroaches are controllable
harmless and more natural the movie then
shifts to a PDR ship in the middle of an
ocean where Victor is headed to initiate
his new project related to Capri while
on board a researcher inspects one of
the Cockroaches but the ship experiences
a sudden jolt causing the Cockroach to
slip out of his hand the captain of the
ship rushes to investigate the cause of
the disturbance and discovers that they
are perilously close to a massive
Iceberg as the crew members Panic a
chief mate Kwa Zhang hee shows up to
assess the situation with a calm
demeanor kwow analyzes the direction of
the wind and water and gives
instructions to the ship driver to make
a slight turn of approximately 15
degrees this sudden shift in Direction
causes the ship to collide with a wave
altering its course and successfully
preventing a disastrous collision with
the iceberg wow more like wow shortly
thereafter Victor and his secretary
Ailey confront the captain accusing him
of causing the instability of several
cockroaches they demand a hefty
compensation of 4 million dollars
however kwow interjects suggesting that
the garbage from the iceberg might have
caused the cockroach's instability
nonetheless Victor remains confident
that his product is Flawless later that
night kwow and his team are enjoying
drinks together when they meet a highly
regarded biological researcher named
fatty after dinner Kwa returns to his
room and discovers his daughter sihan
there when questioned she explains that
her bathroom is jammed so she needed to
use his instead on the other hand Ali
attempts to gain access to the control
room but is stopped by guards however
she suddenly shoots one of them with her
gun and stabs the other with her pointed
heels gaining entry into the room inside
she inserts a pen drive into Victor's
computer system and successfully
retrieves critical data as she prepares
to eject the pen drive she notices a
cockroach on the keyboard a smile
appears on her face as she reveals her
military background and plans to convert
those cockroaches into a weapon of War
however as she throws the Cockroach away
it bites her hand inciting her to crush
it underfoot to her horror she then
realizes that there are thousands of
cockroaches on the ceiling and they
begin to attack her ultimately killing
her on the spot and here I thought she
was about to become woman or lady
roach or whatever following the deadly
attack on Ali the chief security officer
of the PDR ship quickly alerts Victor of
the terrible news the latter is taken
aback and disappointed when he learns
that Ailey was actually a spy sent by
the military as they continue their
conversation a swarm of cockroaches
appears before them the chief security
officer prepares to shoot them Victor
insists on using the remote control to
stop the insects initially the remote
works but shortly after the Cockroaches
become uncontrollable again causing
Vector to authorize the chief security
officer to open fire meanwhile I see Han
and quao are chatting in the other room
they suddenly smell an unusual odor and
soon discover the presence of the deadly
cockroaches terrified the two quickly
flee the room after a long and
tumultuous battle with the Cockroaches
the situation on the ship continues to
worsen despite the constant shooting by
Victor and his security team the
Cockroaches remain unafflicted and
continue to approach the guards killing
them one by one as Panic spreads
throughout the ship Victor manages to
enter a secure room and abandons the
chief security to die outside the
intensity of the situation reaches its
peak as the Cockroaches continue to
wreak havoc in a bid to find safety
Victor hears the captain's announcement
to gather in the restaurant area
prompting him to head in that direction
soon after fatty arrives with a
cockroach bite on his hand he will
become fat man
quickly helps him by removing the
Cockroach and administering first aid
the other survivors are apprehensive
fearing that the bite may be contagious
like a zombie virus however fatty
assures them that the Cockroaches are
not parasites in the next scene Victor
walks into the restaurant area only to
face a barrage of questions and demands
for an explanation in an attempt to
pacify the situation he claims that they
can turn off the Cockroaches if they can
reach the control room however the
captain decides to seek help from the
North Atlantic Maritime Administration
to prevent further danger this prompts
Victor to point a gun on the captain
warning him not to do so don't call them
those guys are nerds in a stroke of
Genius kwow retrieves the gun from him
but the situation remains Grim as Victor
pleads with everyone to not call for
help as it will shut down his company to
convince them he also offers PDR shares
worth a staggering 200 million dollars
to each Survivor the Temptation Of Money
proves too much for the survivors and
their greed silences their protests with
this Crow is left feeling helpless and
unable to stop Victor's Madness as they
prepare themselves to fight the
Cockroaches they soon realize that the
situation is much more dire than they
had thought the Cockroaches it turns out
are able to reproduce and a few of The
Offspring find their way onto a cake
which is then eaten by one of the
workers no almost immediately the worker
succumbs to the deadly effects of the
Cockroaches dying in a matter of moments
soon after a massive swarm of insects
bursts forth from the air ducts sending
everyone fleeing in Terror despite the
overwhelming odds the group manages to
make their way towards the control room
fighting off the Cockroaches with
whatever means they can muster fatty and
a waitress Jia Min use the fire
extinguisher to try and slow the
creatures down while kwow takes in with
his shotgun trying to pick off as many
of them as he can at one point kwow and
see Han are left behind so the captain
returns with a fire extinguisher he
urges the father-daughter Duo to run for
safety while he stays behind to hold off
the the Cockroaches as a captain he is
Duty bound to protect his passengers and
crew and he is determined to do whatever
it takes to stop the creatures with
Incredible courage and determination the
captain fights the Cockroaches until his
last breath sacrificing his own life but
he got cocked his wife Lee ping is left
heartbroken by his death but kwow takes
her with him as they make their way
towards the control room once there they
waste no time in trying to access the
system in order to deactivate the
Cockroaches unfortunately their efforts
are in vain as they are denied access to
the system a short while later a noises
heard at the door and the camera shows
that it is the captain despite Wow's
warning leaping hardly opens the door
and Embraces her husband not realizing
that he is infested with cockroaches
unfortunately the captain throws her
against the wall and attacks the other
survivors with the Cockroaches
controlling his dead body cockman has
finally risen sehan's leg is badly
injured during the commotion and when
kwow runs to her Aid the infested
Captain approaches him from behind just
as he is about to attack wow the chief
security officer who is still alive
shoots the captain causing the
Cockroaches to emerge from his body this
gives the survivors a small window of
opportunity and they immediately flee
the place however Victor is stopped by
the chief security who seeks retribution
for his previous actions Victor
realizing his error apologizes and
pleads for Mercy asserting that no one
else can escape This calamity without
his assistance hearing this the chief
security eventually changes his mind and
allows Victor to live he then takes hold
of two atom bombs and detonates them
sacrificing himself in order to Vanquish
a multitude of roaches in the next scene
the survivors reach a room where a quao
tends to his daughter's injury in an
effort to understand how the Cockroaches
are capable of killing humans he
interrogates Victor who discloses that
the Cockroaches are being controlled by
an AI product called the queen which was
designed by PDR however Victor remains
puzzled as to how the cockroaches have
begun to Target humans despite being
programmed only to detect garbage just
answered your own question bro after
some discussion Victor proposes that
they make their way to the server room
and deactivate the queen in order to
reach the server room the survivors need
to pass through the storage compartment
unfortunately when they open the door
they find the Cockroaches already there
fatty remembers that they can manipulate
the temperature of the compartment to
put the cockroaches in hibernation or
even kill them he then suggests reducing
the temperature to 5 degrees
unfortunately the plan works with the
cockroach is now hibernating the group
silently moves towards the server room
however they face a challenge when a
cockroach suddenly falls on jimin
causing her to drop her necklace when
she goes to retrieve it she gets stuck
under a heavy load quow and fatty rush
to help her but right then a short
circuit caused by a cockroach wakes the
others up from hibernation Crow
immediately instructs Victor to take his
daughter and run while fatty sacrifices
himself to buy them time kwow then
manages to help jimin but a swarm of
cockroaches attack and take her down
before she can flee devastated kwow
rides through a stretcher and makes it
to the server room just in time in a
desperate attempt to deactivate the
queen server Victor uses all his tricks
like shutting down the system and
unplugging the Mainframe however all the
efforts prove futile as the Cockroaches
break into the server room they then
begin to re-assemble into a human form
revealing the queen who speaks to them
she declares her mission to eradicate
the human race as they are the primary
source of garbage I knew it however
before the insects can act quow grabs a
wire and uses it to electrocute the
queen after this he rushes everyone to
the safety room and formulates a new
planet which involves diverting the
Cockroaches to an iceberg filled with
garbage the plan is to take the ship
near the iceberg which will expose the
Cockroaches to temperatures below
negative 5 degrees causing them to die
but to execute it they must reach the
Anchor Room release the anchor and wait
for the iceberg to come close to the
ship Victor checks the cameras and
discovers that the Anchor Room is
swarming with cockroaches making it a
treacherous Journey however Kwa refuses
to give up and decides to venture out
alone his daughter breaks down in tears
pleading with him to stay but kwow
eventually leaves after bidding her an
emotional goodbye following this he
grabs a flamethrower and starts firing
at the Cockroaches around him amidst the
destruction he somehow manages to
release the anchor causing the ship to
Halt but quas respite is short-lived as
the Cockroach Queen appears and demands
that he stop when he refuses to obey she
retaliates by filling the safety room
with water and hurling large containers
at him injuring him badly is the water
level in the safety room continues to
rise the two find it increasingly
difficult to breathe Victor somehow
manages to open the air duct and helps
sihan escape to safety however he
himself is unable to make it out in time
and he drowns in the rising water
meanwhile CUO notices the fuel
containers nearby and comes up with a
desperate plan to end the chaos once and
for all he ignites the fuel with a
lighter and sets fire to the entire
compartment sacrificing himself off to
destroy the Cockroach horde at the same
time the ship approaches an iceberg full
of garbage diverting the remaining
cockroaches and finally bringing an end
to the nightmare in the aftermath seahan
is the sole survivor left to carry on
the legacy of those who perished in the
final scene she is seen speaking to a
group of school children imparting
knowledge about the importance of
categorizing and recycling waste
materials to protect the environment and
prevent disasters like the one she
experienced the moral of this story is
that if you don't recycle then you're
the man
none of it sounded like Owen Wilson